let me pull up this story from the daily
basis a good example Joe Rogan says it's
a fact that January 6 was a false flag
cites Ray Epps now that's a misleading
headline if I've ever seen one but of
course that's The Daily Beast if you are
someone who only consumes garbage
nonsense like The Daily Beast you might
think Joe Rogan's this crazy Alex Jones
guy
however fortunately for Joe Rogan he's
like one of the most famous people on
the planet and many of his fans know who
he really is for these smears they don't
go very far but let me read this for you
they say wildly popular podcaster Joe
Rogan once again pushed baseless the
baseless conspiracy theory I loved it at
the January 6 Capital Insurrection was a
false flag orchestrated by the by the
federal government adding that pro-trump
rioter Ray Epps clearly instigated the
attack now hold on there a minute Ray
Epps is on camera
the night before and the day of telling
people to go to the Capitol and go in
the building he's then seen whispering
in someone's ear and he's on the front
line as the people breach the capitol
grounds
curious they didn't go after him the
feds didn't go after him he was
protected by the media defended by the
media and even now they're trying to
obfuscate what he did it's fascinating
isn't it earlier this month app sued Fox
News for defaming him this we know and
in that lawsuit we're hearing the Epps
may actually be facing criminal charges
they go to mention that Rogan's got a
contract with Spotify blah blah blah
Rogan said the intelligence committee
had a vested interest in this going
sideways adding that if somebody wanted
to disparage a political party or to
maybe have some sort of justification
for getting some influential person like
Trump Offline that would be the way they
would do it and Joe Rogan is completely
correct he was talking to Jim Gaffigan
who did not know anything about this I
gotta tell you when I listen to Joe
Rogan talk to Jim Gaffigan you know I'm
a political guy like I sit here I read
all this news I am just like shaking
wanting to talk to these guys we should
get gath again on the show and be like
ask me any question and I will answer it
and I will show you all the sources I
will pull them up one at a time and you
can by all means not believe the
guardian or NPR the New York Times just
you gotta have some standard do you
believe this out or not do you believe
political or not okay well that's what
we're basing this off of but Jim doesn't
know anything he doesn't know anything
about it so what did Joe Rogan really
say
he said they never went after raps he's
seen on camera instigating the stuff
makes you wonder and now we know what he
said was a fact is that there were guys
there who were uh intelligence assets
encouraging people or I shouldn't say I
should say some kind of government agent
or law enforcement this is not
controversial this is confirmed yeah
they're admitted to doing it to going
let's go let's go hey go go and pushing
people towards the capital oh is that
admitted that agents pushed people
towards the capital there's there's body
camera footage of people who associated
with law enforcement I'd have to pull
this stuff up I'll be very careful here
because I want to make sure we're
getting it right but they're saying
things like go go go when questioned I
think it was uh the FBI said we cannot
like answer were there people involved
at all yeah yeah they pled the fifth
basically and I I did see that clip and
that and and Joe I Joe Rogan cited apps
and he cited you know the FBI director
pleading the fifth
um but yeah it was like early on there
was like very early on after Jan six
there was a New York Times article and
it was like federal agent you know
describes his experience on gen six so
um it's long been acknowledged that
there were federal agents in gen six I
think the strongest uh an argument for
false flag though is the pipe bomb which
apparently they have footage of like the
guy who put it there and they apparently
know where he lives to they've they've
like I I forget where I heard this but
they they know his address and yet they
have not
um prosecuted him or you know explained
what he whether it was a pipe bomb or
not you know what I mean they they it
doesn't look like they've investigated
what that was well that's scandalous
because that guy's like yeah Thomas
Massey has been posting about this and
that is that is kind of piece of in my
opinion that's like the most compelling
evidence because the bombs that were
placed around the capitol heightened the
entire situation to such a level that
you might be able to justify bringing in
federal troops or putting detaining
people without without charge or trial
Jim Gaffigan makes a good question he's
like why didn't Trump call anybody in
why didn't Trump just say get law
enforcement down there right now I think
it's fair to say that Trump was bumbling
quite a bit I don't think Trump had any
intention on anyone going into the
capital I think he genuinely had no idea
what was going on and I don't mean that
he didn't know there were people
storming the capital on one side and
going in another I'm saying he did not
comprehend the situation well have you
you've read though that apparently after
his speech he told Secret Service to
drive him to the Capitol and they said
no we're taking you pretty sure that was
a fake story oh was that because they
claimed that Trump like attacked the
driver well yeah it was exaggerated that
he attacked the driver but what I what I
garnered what I gathered from that was
like if Trump did actually want to go to
the Capitol and talk to these guys could
have been a totally different outcome if
Trump was there and he was like hey guys
we want to do this peacefully as he was
Trump was still speaking when they were
breaching the capitol grounds oh okay
right but either way if he had gotten
there he could you know he could have
ended it
um and so it's weird that secret service
would say no we're not letting you go
and it's weird that Trump couldn't
override that with just a direct order
also so you know yep I got personal
criticisms I mean I wasn't the president
president had held a job during covid
man but the way he didn't send in
federal troops during the Riots of 2020.
President did a hell of a job during
covet well no you think operation Wars
no I don't think he did a good job I
mean the president has a hell of a job
during something like that is what I
mean and he so I can't talk too much
about him and like be like well if
I was there I would have this and that
because like backseat driving to
hindsight's 2020. but he didn't send in
the troops day one of the 2020
insurrections whatever the hell these
these Street riots that broke out after
George Floyd death I would told Tim the
next day like where the National
Guard what are we waiting for this is
going to spread out of control this is
like a fire burning right now and it did
two days three days later two days later
the whole the city's starting to get
burned down and I'm like where's the
president of the United States the armed
chief of our military commander like
and he probably I think he was so afraid
of being called a fascist he didn't want
to invoke he didn't want to bring the
troops in and then the same so where
were the troops I want to make sure we
get this in the segment this is an
article from wlos.com an FBI informant
embedded within the proud voice on
January 6 identified in the record only
by the name Aaron testified for the
defense the witness said he was not
aware of any plans by the proud boys to
invade the U.S Capitol building so
that's one simple example we then have
this this is a filing uh this is a
defense writing the doj recently
disclosed involvement of undercover
office informants from other agencies
aside from the FBI and D.C metro police
at least 40 undercover informants so
that was one of the big stories there's
there was another uh there were another
couple videos that came out and uh you
guys should definitely fact check me on
this one it is hard to do because most
of the cover press ignores this stuff
but there were a few videos from law
enforcement who were shouting things
like I think the video in question was
let's go let's go keep going keep going
or something like that
well that's fascinating because that if
that's true then that that's kind of the
Crux of the whole false fact false flag
claim so if that's true then Joe Rogan
was in fact correct well no no the
question Joe Rogan asked whether or not
the possibility of a false flag could be
and whether it made sense and it
certainly does make sense they used the
Insurrection thing for two years just
screaming non-stop over and over again
on TV that it was an Insurrection and
now the speculation is they'll try to
use this to get Trump removed from the
ballot so certainly there was a benefit
to all of this they deleted Trump's
tweets calling for peace they deleted
Trump's Facebook posts where he was
saying I don't think they they suspended
him Trump had said things like everybody
go home we respect law enforcement they
Shuffle that away and then claim he was
calling for violence
um you know if you're a commander and
you've got us your capital is under
siege by its own civilians like in their
they're starting a riot or they're
starting thing like you've got a few
options you know you can bring out the
guns and try and turn them down that you
can ask beg them to stop which doesn't
really work against large crowds or you
can insert well active do like Duty
Officers into the crowd to break it up
from inside that's one of the smartest
methods Joe Rogan points out the WTO
protests in Seattle they call the battle
for Seattle they had agent provocateurs
there we we've seen videos there's a lot
of speculation all the time about agent
provocateurs there was one story in
Canada where protesters had military
style boots started acting violently the
left has argued this for a long time
they conveniently forget the possibility
when it comes to the right why they're
happy it happened you had the gravel
Institute tweeting in support of January
6 except for the fact that there was
right wing they actually tweeted that it
was good what happened it was just bad
that it was conservatives or
right-wingers that were doing it they
like it when it comes to agent
provocateurs the left will tell you to
your face the government stages fake
activists to incite violence for the
purpose of discrediting protest
movements and then when the right is
protesting the left says I have no you
were talking about
and here you are yeah you can make the
same argument for election fraud as well
yep yeah we need people to stand up for
the rights of other the people you don't
agree with like if you see maybe it's a
big ask but if you see your political
opponents under duress and they're being
treated poorly or illegally you've got
to stand up for those people yeah you
need to stand on Principle as opposed to
a certain degree there's a certain
degree there is no there is no history
there there's no evidence of that
happening from really from either side
but definitely from the Democrats for
the past 15 20 years and that's why I
say to a certain degree because perhaps
when the country is Unified but there's
partisan bickering you get angry when a
when the doj is weaponized against a
political group you say hey guys you
can't do that unfortunately right now
we're in something substantially deeper
than that and now the question is when
they're trying to destroy you do you
provide them with your support yes first
time my life I've ever been in a
situation like where they were in the
50s where they were really afraid the
Communists were going to take over the
country so they were like the was a
jagger Hoover's Blacklist or whatever he
like started blacklisting all these
people that had communist ties and
people were losing their jobs and their
careers and like maybe if they hadn't
done that we would have become a
communist election so I don't know do
you know that uh Communists are excluded
from the Civil Rights Act yeah
uh yeah I think I didn't know that this
is still true to this day and I got
questions about the legal uh merits of
that it's in the law and it's not I do
not believe it's been adjudicated so I
wonder what would happen if you were
just like no Communists allowed this is
just this is like I I don't have any
kind of evidence is just my my
impression but the in the 50s in the Red
Scare and stuff and I really need to go
and do more reading about like what it
was actually like
um but it really seemed like the people
that were really opposed to Communism in
the in the 50s and 60s it seemed like
they really understood that the left the
the international left has a fundamental
different uh understanding of the world
I was listening to uh this book called
uh this audiobook called explaining
post-modernism by Stephen Hicks and one
of the things that he talks about is the
way that
the way that the left doesn't have the
same kind of foundation that the right
does and it's about you know liberalism
versus authoritarianism and you're not
going to be able to find common ground
with people that have a fundamental
different understanding of what the
truth is or what reality is and and if
there is no truth then it's fine to use
ad hominems and call everybody Nazis and
stuff and we're seeing the effects of
that now it's it's been
20 or 30 years the about 30 or 40 years
now actually that the left is called
everybody on the right a Nazi and every
president's a Nazi and it always goes to
the absolute worst where you know
there's a lot of people in America now
that aren't unfortunately that are not
so afraid of the word of being called a
racist anymore you know they're just
like well you call everybody that you
call everybody Nazi you call everybody
so it doesn't matter and they'll that's
something that we have to deal with and
I don't I don't see how we can deal with
with the the struggles that we're having
as a country if if we can't even agree
on what the philosophy that the United
States is is founded on but hold on but
hold on because what you you're giving
credit to the people in the 1950s and
you're kind of saying well they were
actually good intention and they were
actually against Communists and pro
Freedom I'm only saying that maybe they
understood better than the average
person now I'm not trying to give them a
undue credit but then you talk about the
difference in ideology which is one is
uh collectivism one is individualism and
I agree I'm a big individualist but when
you go on this like Red Scare campaign
you're immediately dissolving one of the
crucial things of individualism which is
like one of the ones until proven guilt
yes one of the the flaws or one of the
the greatest challenges that liberalism
has is liberalism accepts the arguments
of opposing viewpoints as if they are
coming from liberals right so you if you
enter the disagreement expecting your
your the person you're having a debate
with to be honest but they're not going
to be honest you can never ever come out
you can never have a a fair exchange so
that's one of the things that liberals
have to figure out how to deal with and
that's why that's why liberals and
that's why the Communists say liberals
always choose fascists over Communists
because the only way that you can fight
authoritarians is with authoritarianism
right but then you become like the
monster you're trying to fight like it's
what Tim said with like the original uh
purpose of like these International
bodies and then the grandchildren just
forget what the purpose was like look at
what the FBI is now look at what the CIA
is now yeah but how could you say that
they were always that way
yeah and if you look at J Edgar Hoover
they were always that way so I I just
don't think there's any Credence to this
argument of like we need to embrace into
our terrorism to get rid of no I'm not I
didn't say that we need to embrace I
didn't say we need to embrace it but I'm
I'm saying that
the current problem that we have is that
liberalism doesn't have
a it doesn't have a mechanism for to
deal with it
but it does like the price is only
supporting liberalism and not supporting
other ideologies fair enough but the
point the problem that that we're
experiencing now is authoritarians lie
to liberals Libs bad liberals they
lie to Libs and Libs believe
them because what the what the
authoritarians are telling the Liberals
sounds good but so the tool then is is
education and it's very difficult
obviously especially with Echo Chambers
but to me that's the only viable tool
and that was another Jefferson quote
something about educating the masses is
like how to secure Liberty a lot of
times with tone because the data itself
doesn't convince people yeah and another
shout out to Dave Smith because I think
he does that extremely well thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time